each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so today I'm very pleased to have
Vinod vicodin 11 visiting to speak to us
on side channels and clouds so now I've
gotten over my big hurdle for the day so
it pronounced against the last name so
we're very pleased to have him visiting
he's currently a postdoctoral fellow at
IBM and he did his PhD at MIT and with
shafi Goldwasser 2009 where he won the
best dissertation award from the
computer science department Thank You
vena thanks Kristen before I start the
talk I have to tell you that Kristen
told me before the doc that she wants to
ask me a lot of questions I really want
to encourage you guys to do the same
let's make this interactive so the topic
of this the stock is side channels and
clouds new challenges in cryptography
the the development of cryptography has
always gone hand in hand with the
emergence of new computing technology
whenever there is a big change in the
way we do computation or think about
computation it is always led to problems
and challenges for cryptography and
ultimately we face these challenges we
have managed to come up with new
techniques in cryptography in fact we
can see if you look back at the history
of cryptography we can see a number of
examples of this such as the development
of automated ways of doing cryptography
of encrypting messages for example the
the unequal machine of the 1930s the
invention of public key cryptography in
the 1970s and so on and so forth
today in the 21st century we standard
the brink of another big change in the
way we do computing a lot of computing
these days is being done on small and
mobile devices which is computing out
there in the world in an environment
that we do not necessarily trust where
is we used to think of data being stored
and programs being executed in a
personal computer sitting right in our
office and our control we these days we
do a lot of our computing on devices
such as laptops cell phones our Phi D
devices and so on and so forth the
problem with these the problem with this
change in the way we do computing is
that these devices store sensitive data
and they're just out there computing
where the adversary the attacker has an
unprecedented level of access to these
devices and control over these devices
he has a lot of the devices are becoming
closer and closer to the adversary and
that's becoming that's making it much
easier for the adversary to carry out
attacks the second big change that we
see in cryptography in computing is that
the amount of data that we need to store
and the amount of computation we need to
perform on this data is becoming so huge
that the end users are not willing to do
all of it themselves either because they
simply do not have the resources to do
so or various other reasons instead what
they do is they outsource storage and
computing to big third-party vendors
such as Microsoft Google Amazon and so
forth in this trend is called cloud
computing and it is again a big concern
in terms of cryptography because we are
putting our data and programs out there
away from our trusted personal computers
this new computing reality poses to new
challenges for cryptography which will
be the focus of my talk
first of all in in cryptography we
traditionally think of cryptographic
devices as black boxes in other words
what this means is that the only way an
attacker the assumption is that the only
way an attacker can access the
cryptographic system is by giving it
input and receiving the output of the
computation what's really going on
inside the device is you know he has no
clue what's what's going on the real
world is quite different and in fact it
turns out that there are various
mechanisms by which computing devices
leak information to the outside wall not
just throw input/output access in
particular the an attacker can can avail
of a large family of attacks called
side-channel attacks which reveal extra
information about the storage about the
data stored inside the device and the
computation being / performed a site
analytics utilize the the fact that
physical characteristics of computation
such as the amount of time for which a
particular program runs the power
consumed by running a piece of software
or in fact something non-invasive such
as the electromagnetic radiations
emitted by the computation emitted by
the device during the computation all
these physical characteristics leak more
information about the computation than
just input-output access and these this
extra information leakage is actually
actually been successfully utilized to
break many existing cryptographic
systems so one thing they want to say
before I go further is that these
attacks are not completely new they've
existed for well over a couple of
decades what is what makes them
particularly acute and interesting in
this in this context is the physical
proximity that the attacker has to these
devices this is the result of our you
know the new sort of computing reality
that we're facing another point I want
to make is a DC tax and not just
theoretical attacks their actual attacks
on implementations of standardized
crypto systems such as our say advanced
encryption standards and these have been
attacked very successfully using
side-channel attacks
so this is sort of a real concern for us
so the first challenge challenge number
one that I will address is can we
protect against this kind of information
leakage can we protect against
side-channel attacks okay so that's
that's number one the second challenge
appears in the context of cloud
computing the context of security in
cloud computing the general setting of
cloud computing is one in which there is
a client and a server the client has
some input data and she wants to do some
computation on the input data and but
the point is that she may not have
enough resources to do the computation
or might otherwise be unwilling to do
this computation herself so what she
does is she she sends the data across to
the server which does the computation on
her behalf this general this is a very
general setting and specific examples of
the setting are specific familiar
examples of the setting of the context
of searching the internet using Bing for
example to search the internet but this
is also interesting in the modern
context in a more general scenario where
the server performs an arbitrary
computation on the input data so first
of all the client may not be willing to
disclose her entire data to the server
why would it right so the client demands
privacy of a data and one way to achieve
privacy of our data is for her to
encrypt the data and send it over to the
server don't send the data in the clear
interrupt it but now we are in a little
bit of a problem because what the server
gets is encrypted data it doesn't even
see what's inside the ciphertext and yet
it's supposed to perform some it's
supposed to execute the program it's
supposed to perform some meaningful
computation on the underlying data so
the question is can we reconcile these
opposing goals of privacy and
functionality so in more country terms
our challenge number two is can we
compute on encrypted data okay
so these are the two challenges I'm
going to address in this stock and the
talk will go in in three parts in the
first part I will show a mechanism to to
protect against side channel leakage but
this is a hugely active area in
cryptography at this point many many
many models of how side channels behave
and many constructions of cryptographic
primitives there are secure against side
channels in this talk I will tell you
about a simple model for side channels
and a solution at a construction of a
particular cryptographic primitive that
is secure in this model this is joint
work with adia kavya and shafiqul wazoo
in the second part of the talk I will
describe mechanism to compute on
encrypted data this is done using a very
powerful a cryptographic primitive
called a fully homomorphic encryption
scheme and this work is joined with
Martin Van Dyke gently and shyla finally
I'll tell you about a sub my research
philosophy and a bunch of open questions
and future directions so this is the
structure of the talk and probably this
is a good point to stop see if everyone
is on the same page ok wonderful so
let's jump right in but one how to
protect against side channels the the
traditional approach to handle
side-channel attacks has been to to
address side channels as they come along
in other words for for each particular
kind of attack design a tailor-made
solution that handles this attack so
that has been so the traditional way of
looking at this problem and this can be
done in hardware namely manufacture
specific types of hardware that protect
against specific attacks you can modify
program so that they resist in a
particular kinds of attack so one sort
of little drawback with with both these
both these solutions is that they are
usually ad hoc and they don't come with
a proof for a guarantee that they
actually do the job solutions have also
been explored in SF a higher level
setting in an algorithmic setting when
people have considered
leakage of specific bits of the secret
so let's leak the first bit and fifty
fifty a bit 100 bins over this is a very
specific kind of leakage again people
have explored this in a in a number of
works so this general approach of
solving side channels has two problems
one is the one is a scalability of this
kind of solution so every time you want
to protect against a new side channel
attack you have to you know incur the
cost of building in a new type of
counter measure and in other words that
the cost of your solution grows as the
number of side channels that you want to
protect against yes serious about your
distinguishing between algorithmic in
the software tax you think there's a lot
of overlap I'm not sure I really
distinguish them sure so the line is a
little bit then in that in that case but
what I mean by software is that I take a
specific program so one approach that
people have exploded to counteract
timing attacks is to make sure that the
program runs for the same amount of time
on every input right that's not an
algorithm so the line is a little bit
then but uh good so the first problem
with this with this line of attack is
its scalability the cost grows is the
number of side channels we need to
protect against the second more subtle
and you know a probably more serious
problem is the composability it is to
roughly explain this problem the problem
is that if I build in a solution that
protects against one side channel and
you know build in another solution that
protects against the second side channel
who said that the effects of these side
channels won't cancel each other the
question is do the different protection
protection mechanisms work well with
each other that may not be the case in
fact people have done a lot of work in
studying the effect of these
countermeasures in an effect that they
have on each other so there are a couple
of problems with this traditional
specific approach to counteracting side
channels what we will look at today is a
modern approach the modern approach is
to say you know let's step back and
let's try to come up with a model that
captures the white class of side
channels and design a solution in this
MA
and you know if you if your model
captures a large class of side channels
the solution will be secure against all
these attacks as well this approach was
advocated and pioneered by Macaulay and
raising so in other words instead of
looking at each of these side channel
attacks one by one what we want to do is
we want to define a model of the
adversary that interacts with this
system and this model should capture all
these attacks in one go and once you
come up with this model you want to
construct cryptographic primitives and
prove that they're secure in this model
yes new website channel attackers exam
illiterate a simpler produce a journal
of texts keep the crypto stuff in a very
secure location and don't let anybody in
and except for timing attack seems to be
a pretty good idea yeah so it is but the
the attacks still don't prevent you know
people are measuring the electromagnetic
radiation that come out from my cell
phone they kind of walking around for
example if it was serious canvas good at
some party cage but then you don't get
portability which is important yes yeah
probably for something that can differ
driving for part of knowledge or good
workability so I so I put my phone on a
puddle of dirt a cage my kind of punch
the is tweeting grill okay anyway
keep going good point okay good so this
is what this is the general approach
that we want to take and this is a as I
said before this is a very active very
recent and very active area of research
and with the number of models and
matching results aside from the results
that I that I mentioned before many
other researchers have come up with
various different kinds of models and
constructions of cryptographic
parameters what I'm going to talk about
today is one specific result the work
with the idea cavion chief eagle was it
in which we propose a simple model and
the construction of a particular
cryptographic primitives that is secure
in this model that's what we are going
to talk about today
so the model we propose is called the
bounded leakage model and the starting
observation to to this model is that if
you allow the side channel to leak an
unbounded amount of information it is
really nothing you can do because the
information could be the entire secret
contained in the device itself so one
sort of necessary condition that you
think one condition that seems to be
necessary is to put an limitation on the
amount of information that the side
channel lakes and that's that's that's
our first restriction we say that the
amount of leakage is less than the
length of the secret key in fact it's a
parameter I ssible quantity the larger
this amount is the more secure you get
and the right support this is so the
first requirement that we post on side
chopped the second observation is that
if you allow the side channel unlimited
computing power then it can break the
crypto system itself right i mean
there's this not no way you can protect
against such a side channel and that
leads to our second restriction we say
that the side channel should be the
computation done by the side channel
which is an antenna for electromagnetic
radiation or your oscilloscope for a
power attack it's paulo melee bounded
that's your second restriction leakage
to be less than one tricky no no no a
lot less than like to see in fact in
fact it's a parameter I small quantity I
should say that it's possible to this is
a very basic model and I'm presenting
this because of simplicity in fact it's
possible to relax both these conditions
in particular the information limitation
quite a bit and i'll be happy to talk
about this one-on-one ok so this is the
model this is a sort of the abstract
model that we will work with today yes
first restriction our adversary or it's
a restriction on d so if you think about
side channels there are two entities
right one is me I'm the attacker that
I'm using a particular hardware device
to get some measurement on the under
computation there are two two entities
here one is the attacker one is the
device and the restriction is on the
under device and the amount of
computation that amount of information
that the device gives me and the amount
of computation that it can do does that
answer your question so you're saying
that this look that this will only work
if the device just naturally weeks less
information the key that's why
absolutely and in fact you can see that
if the device leaks you know the amount
of information that leaks is more than
the length of the secret key it could
just like the entire secret key itself
right potentially so good so good so
this is the model that will work with
today and the rest of this part of the
talk i'm going to use public key
encryption as my example primitive and
let's let's refresh our mind about what
public interruption is in this setting
there are two people Bob Munden Alice
Bob wants to send a message to Alice
privately over a public channel and the
way she does it the way he does it is by
letting Alice choose two keys secretly
and a publicly publicly you publish the
secretly you keep with Alice keeps with
herself and Bob has a mechanism to use
the public key to encrypt the message
send it over to Alice on the public
channel now this can use for secret key
to decrypt it's a simple very simple
setting
and what the attacker can do the
attacker that we will look at the
setting is an eavesdropping attacker I
mean that's the so the most basic model
often there's a most basic attack that
you can perform on a public key
encryption scheme the attacker gets
access to the public key it's out there
in the in the open so you can look at it
it looks at the ciphertext because it's
going through a public channel and it
tries to gain some information about the
underlying message and the security
requirement the basic the classical
security requirement is that the
attacker has no information about the
underlying message crazy right public
you well cuz it's got the MIT marks are
right does your offices oh boy okay
aside from that no I'm just very
surprised that you can
no building is fairly yeah ja we want to
talk about the bounded leakage model and
the change that we make to the security
game is very simple we instead of in
addition to letting the adversary get
the public key and the ciphertext we
also let him ask the decryption Oracle
the description box for a leakage
function f so this is the leakage
function that's computed by either the
oscilloscope or iran's nah i mean this
is this one that models both these
leakages and i sort of salt he gets back
the function f applied on the secret all
right so this is a very sort of simple
extension to the classical security
model so obviously you know following
our discussion before we need to have
two restrictions on the on the leakage
function f1 is that it has bounded
output length and this is sort of a
parameter is sort of a sliding scale the
more the output length is the more the
leakages and the better your security
gets the second restriction is that a
function is Paolo mealtime computable
okay so this is this is the sort of the
concrete model for public interruption
that that will talk about so now we have
a model the question is are there
encryption schemes that are secure in
this model that protect against this
class of attacks so let's first look at
well-known encryption schemes
interruption schemes that we know and
love so unfortunately it turns out that
the RSA encryption scheme is insecure
against bounded leakage there are a
number of results that show that if you
leak a Const small constant fraction of
the secret key you can break the entire
cryptosystem so our say is out of
question as for the el-gamal encryption
scheme there is no explicit attack that
that that breaks the system with leakage
but there is no real guarantee or proof
that it's secure either so unfortunately
these two systems
not good for us what we show is that a
new word class of encryption schemes
based on mathematical objects called
lattices are in fact secure against
boundary leakage these are not the
mathematical basis for these systems is
not factoring or discrete log but it's a
different kind of object halitosis so we
show that an encryption scheme proposed
by Raghav is secure against leaking akan
any constant fraction of the bits of the
secret key say 99 percent or 99.99
percent and subsequently in work with
dodi's Goldwasser client weichert we
showed that a different encryption
scheme based on lattices also has this
property the interesting thing that I
want to point out is that these
encryption schemes were not explicitly
designed with leakage in mind they were
designed for a completely different
purpose it just so happens that the
leakage resilience is built into them
okay so that's what we show and
following your work a number of other
constructions were shown to be leakage
resilient as well some of them based on
more standard assumptions such as the
diffie-hellman assumption and also so
the class of constructions based on
what's called hash proof systems they
were also shown to be secure against
boundary kitchen ehh good so this is dan
Bonnie from Stanford Shia levy Mike
handbook and rock your Starsky good so
so there are all these constructions in
the rest of this part of the talk I'm
not going to focus on any of these
specific instructions but instead will
step back and ask the question what is
it that makes these games slick its
resilience liquid resilient is there
some kind of underlying structure or a
principle behind these schemes which you
know which makes it which makes them
secure against these attacks
in fact i will show two principles to
ideas such that if an encryption scheme
satisfies these two principles two
conditions then it's automatically
secure against boundary leakage in fact
all these encryption schemes that I
showed in the previous slide actually
satisfy these restrictions so you can
think of this as sort of a way to
explain why these schemes are linkage
resilient the first idea the world the
first property that I require from an
encryption scheme is that given a public
key there are many possible secret keys
in fact I will require that there are
exponentially many possible secret keys
for any given publicly so if you're used
to thinking about our essay or el-gamal
this is a sort of a foreign concept
because in our say the public is product
of two primes the secret key is its
unique factorization so although you
can't compute the secret key efficiently
given the public key it is uniquely
determined the secret key you or I say
Christian exponent which chris there
midea code hey good so you can you can
add a multiple look yes so I'm gonna I'm
going to get to a tournament okay so
this is the this is the first property
require and of course the encryption
algorithm when it encrypts a message it
is no clue which secretly the decription
box contains it could be one of these
exponentially many possibilities and
therefore correctness of the encryption
scheme requires that any of these secret
keys decrypt the ciphertext to the same
message in fact and in fact the message
that the ciphertext originally interrupt
so in other words all these secret keys
are functionally equivalent they all
decrypt the ciphertext to the exact same
message and yet even though their
functional equivalent we will show that
partial information about any single
secret key is totally useless to the
attacker so let's actually think about
this idea so step back and think about
this idea for a little bit to answer
Josh this question like so you can take
any encryption scheme any encryption
scheme that you like and you can make it
have this property so you can take the
secret key and fat it with a bunch of
random nonsense I mean so the number of
secretly is gross but we haven't really
done anything right so this idea by
itself is not particularly useful what
makes it useful is the second idea in
the second idea the second property that
I require from the interruption scheme
is that there are two distinct ways to
generate a ciphertext one is the way
that Bob uses two to encrypt this
message this takes a message uses the
public key and computer ciphertext this
is what Bob does in the real world the
second way to generate a ciphertext what
I will call a fake encryption algorithm
the fake encryption algorithm is is fake
I mean it's never no one ever execute
this in the real world it's just not a
fact of the proof it's just a sort of
mental experiment that exists because
it's a mental experiment it exists
because we want to prove this game
secure so fake interruption scheme is a
randomized algorithm that takes nothing
no input
and just produces a random cypher text
and the ciphertext behaves very
differently from a real ciphertext the
sense that if you take the ciphertext
and decrypt it with any of the possible
exponentially many keys you will get a
different message every time so if I
take a random one of these secret keys
and decrypt the ciphertext I will get a
random message so functionally the
ciphertext behaves very different from a
real ciphertext yes why are your
sufficiency is good presumably nothing's
wrong about their necessity of these
ideas are you have an answer no no I
don't so so in fact a couple of flights
before I mentioned that el gamal is not
known to be secure in this setting so it
turns out that el-gamal encryption
scheme does not satisfy either of these
properties but we have no clue if it's
secure or not so I'm not sure I'm not
sure that these ideas are necessary but
this is one way to to achieve security
because they're all short is vector
based and you have a lot of ritalin for
short bankers I mean it is that where
you're getting this from so just a brief
sort of a overview of these latter
solutions in the lattice and the lattice
based encryption schemes the public key
is a point in space and an n-dimensional
space and the secret key is any vector
any lattice vector that is close to this
point so depending on how you define
close there could be an exponential
number of points that are close that's
that's what contributes and of course it
still doesn't explain why this game
satisfies this are the property but just
a screw behind you good so let's fake
include the fixed I protects behaves
very differently from the real site X
and yet we require that if I see a fake
ciphertext in one hand and the real
cipher text on the other I can't tell
which is which so fake ciphertext is
indistinguishable from the rails left
with that so even if you know the secret
key even if you know the secret key even
if you know a single secretly our site
10 so if you if you know too
to the same thing with different yes but
the other one will want so you can't up
but if you know a single secret game RDR
do we do yeah but so this is the second
property we need and now I'm going to
show that if you have these two
properties that's that you get leakage
resilience okay so the first step in the
in the insert the prune the waiter see
why this works is to look at the fake
world and the fake ciphertext right the
fake ciphertext obviously contains it
was generated without the knowledge of
the public key or message so it contains
no information about any message
whatsoever in fact a the fake phifertex
decrypts to a random message under the
choice of a random secretly but this is
just this is what happens with when the
adversary is given just the fake
ciphertext right so what if it's also
given some amount of leakage from the
secret key okay so let's look at that
let's say he gets one bit of leakage
from the secret key right so originally
from his view the number of possible
secret keys was exponentially largely
all these like huge amount of
secretaries if I get one bit of
information about the set that narrows
down the set by a factor of half so the
number of possible secret keys it's
reduced by a factor of half two bits
right I mean it becomes a quarter if I
get a bounded amount of information
about the secret key there is still a
quite a bit of possibilities that are
left in the left us I secretly and of
course each of these random one of these
secret Keys decrypts to a random message
and still the attack therefore still the
attacker has no clue what the message
what the messengers okay so far it's
everything happened in the fake wall and
we don't even care about what the fake
one is right but the key thing to
observe is that a ciphertext that
happens in the it's produced in the fake
world it's indistinguishable from a
ciphertext in the real world so the
adversary is not going to know the
difference if it gets a fake ciphertext
or real life real ciphertext therefore
it has no information about the message
either right it didn't have any
information about the
message in the fake world why would it
have any information in the real world
that's that I mean that's the that's the
end of the pro right and that actually
finishes what I wanted to I just told
you about a model a simple model for
side channels and a way to construct a
public interruption scheme that is their
secure in this model that finishes my
section on side channels is there any
this is this evening buzzing you
corresponding cipher in plain text
feltham at all a hole and you knew
ciphertext potentially so students so
this is a sort of a strong attack that
you're mentioning is a stronger attack
called a chosen cipher or I guess I'm
known ciphertext oh yeah potentially it
could but I think again yeah don't hold
it don't hold me to this but I think I
can show that this scheme is secure
against a known ciphertext attack cipher
text message pairs and that's simply
because it's a public interruptions game
right I can I can I can construct
messages in cipher text by myself but it
shows in cipher text attack is a
different issue and this may not
actually be secure duh we can we can
take this off yes how do I know if my
sister only leaks a very small valid
that's an engineer scrub that's it okay
if I put in antenna and you're smart
card yes aren't you you're leaking
continuous data over it you know even
over about a long time how do I know
that there's no bit in there hey how do
you know that the leakage doesn't sort
of uniquely you can't recover the
uniquely unique secretly from so the the
I'm gonna borrow John's answer say that
this is an engineer's problem but did
your motivational talk was all these
countermeasures and engineers put in
there yes they're heuristics and they
don't really add any formal proof to
what it is you're doing and they look
we're gonna have weight on it proxim so
want me to look at this the solution is
that if you can guarantee to me that the
amount of information leaked by this
particular attack is bounded I'm going
to tell you I'm going to show you a
provable way to protect against this
attack so really the salute you can you
should think of the solution as a
combination of a hardware countermeasure
and an algorithmic countermeasure you
give me the guarantee that the amount of
information is bounded here is the
solution mansion is just a rounded champ
I a couple of different answers to your
question maybe we can okay so this is
the this is what I wanted to say about
side channels let's move on the second
part is how to compute on encrypted data
so again let's let's remind ourselves of
of our motivating example there's a
client and the server the client sends
an encrypted data to the server and the
server has to perform computation on the
encrypted data and send back the
encrypted result this makes sense in
various specific context for example
encrypted internet search which it turns
out that for specific instantiations of
this problem there are already sort of
tailor-made solutions that that's all
that's all these cases for example
searchable encryption is a cryptographic
mechanism that solves interpret internet
search but what we are really concerned
about today is performing general
computation on interpret data a
cryptographic tool that is it is really
helpful in this general context is
called fully homomorphic encryption
that's what I will talk about the rest
of the talk good so yes I saw the latest
on the employee the user now the same
design back to the user correct Abe well
the question is what does it mean for it
could be that we want to protect the
program against so it could be that the
client doesn't know what program the
server is running and I want to hide
this fact from her but that's that's
sort of a different concern that that we
are not going to focus on is you Caro
partly wanted results yes that's what
that's what the goals
but you did anyway again
well another way to look at another way
to answer your question is that the the
computation on the encrypted data is
performed without the knowledge of the
secret key right mean it's a public
computation anyone can do this so the
information that the interrupted result
leaks cannot be any more than what the
original ciprodex Lakes because I'm
performing some public computation on
the encrypted data right so okay so this
is the problem that very concerned with
so we're going to model a program an
arbitrary program as a boolean circuit
like I mean any so if you go down to the
most basic level you can write any
computation as a combination of
exclusive or gates and and gates so i'm
going to write this as a big boolean
circuit so i'm going to look at
exclusive our exclusive our is really
edition in in the field of size 2 and
and this multiplication so that's it's
an equivalence i'm going to go to use so
what is the fully homomorphic encryption
scheme a fully homomorphic encryption
scheme is a scheme where you can compute
the and function on to encrypted bits
and the exclusive our function on doing
total bits you can add and multiply
encrypted data and because you can write
any computation as a combination of
ant-and- our gates if you can do both
these you can do everything right so so
that's that's a fully homomorphic
encryption what do we know about their
fully homomorphic encryption scheme this
sort of concept was first defined by the
name of privacy homomorphism by reversed
Adelman and dirty sauce already in 1978
when they didn't really have a candidate
scheme that satisfied their definition
so it was such an insightful sort of act
of foresight that uh they define this
without even having the candidate escape
and their motivation was actually the
modern motivation for constructing these
schemes namely searching on encrypted
data
what we know so far a limited variance
of home Norfolk encryption for example
the DRC scheme we know that it's a
multiplicative Lee homomorphic for
example if I give you encryption of one
message and a different message I can
compute the encryption of the product of
the two messages that's something you
can do the el-gamal and the kielbasa
McCauley encryption schemes added to be
homomorphic you can add interrupted
plain text but you can't multiply them
there are also mechanisms that compute
very limited classes of functions on
encrypted bits namely quadratic formulas
but the real question is can you do
arbitrary computation on encrypted data
and that has been open for nearly 30
years until last year Craig Gentry
constructed the first sort of
instantiation of a fully homomorphic
encryption scheme this construction was
based on very sophisticated new
mathematics based on ideals in now in
polynomial rings so fully homomorphic
encryption scheme is a really very
powerful object and this lets you do a
lot of very nice useful things the
question that Gentry's construction
races is is there a simple way simple
and elementary way of achieving fully
homomorphic encryption I don't want to
have to learn algebraic number theory to
understand
aaj break access so the question is is
there an elementary construction of the
subject so in other words the question
we want to ask is what simple
mathematical objects can you both add
and multiply that both permit addition
and multiplication so what we show is a
construction of a fully homomorphic
encryption scheme based on integers
namely the the operations the basic
operations in the scheme is just
addition and multiplication plain
addition and multiplication of integers
no ideals no polynomial drinks just
simple operations not something a
integer smart something because a bigger
the thing we will have the penalty for
the general function make that brief
right good good I'm more afraid of
number cost function than offering to
learn new bath the answer is kind of
unfortunate if you're frightened by the
cost of generation so you'll be really
frightened by but but but the point is
that the point I'm trying to make is
that you can improve on a construction
only if you understand it right you have
sort of a good idea of how this
encryption scheme behaves and therefore
what we should do is construct simple
Elementary in our encryption schemes
good so be sure to constructions one
based on integers and the security of
the scheme is based on the approximate
GCD problem now the second construction
uses addition and multiplication of
matrices and this game is not fully
homomorphic it can only evaluate a
limited set of functions namely
quadratic formulas the security of this
is based on standard well-studied
lattice problems so what I'm going to
talk about is the integer based
construction
good so let's jump in to the to the
scheme so first of all what I'm going to
describe we've been talking about public
interruption all over the place but what
I'm going to describe to you is a secret
key homomorphic encryption scheme namely
to encrypt a message I need the secret
key and I decrypt the message decrypt
the ciphertext using the same secretly
so that's that's the setting in fact
this setting is already useful in the
context of a cloud computing because the
sender and the receiver are the same
entertain because how does interruption
skip work well the secret key is an
n-bit n is pretty large and bit odd
number p so that's the secret key how do
i encrypt a bit p i'm going to talk
about interruption schemes that encrypt
a single bit for simplicity how do i
interrupt a bit be i pick a large
multiple of P let's say Q times P Q is a
very large number I'm going to pick a
small number small even number two times
are and i'm going to add all these
quantities together with the message so
the ciphertext is Q times B its large
number plus the small noise term two
times R plus B that's the ciphertext
okay how do I decrypt this the
ciphertext first of all if i take the
cipher i have the secret key and the
decryption algorithm i have the secret
key if i take the ciphertext and take it
modulo P what i get is the noise term
it's two times r plus p in fact the key
thing to note is that I get the exact
noise term I do not get two times R plus
B mart be I get that number by itself
whether that's an important thing to
note now once I have this noise term I
can just read off the least significant
bit and that that's that's the
decryption algorithm ok so this is the
entire encryption scale
any questions questions comments good
wonderful so this is the interruption
scheme what I didn't tell you is how to
add and multiply encrypted bits so
that's the next thing in gradually how
to add much more in trouble bits and in
a high level additional multiplication
works because if I take a cipher text
and another cipher text and add or
multiply them together the noise term is
still going to be small assuming that
the original noise is really small the
noise terms are not going to grow by too
much yes success and success your
messages same key No so that's part of
the so that's part of the assumption so
the assumption is that if I give you
many the approximate GCD assumption is
that if I give you many near multiples
of be like large multiple plus noise it
is indistinguishable you you can't
recover me that's the Assumption so good
so additional multiplication works in
high level because the noise terms do
not grow by too much when you adn't
multiply numbers okay so let's let's
look at it more concretely let's take
two ciphertext one encrypting a bit be
one and the other one encrypting veto
and addition of the underlying bits is
done by simply adding these two numbers
as integers so when you add these two
numbers I get a multiple of P I get a
nice term which is slightly bigger than
the original noise because I added two
of these things together plus the the
sum of the two bits alright so now if I
take this sum of the two numbers mod B
and I read off the leasing least
significant bit I get the exclusive are
of the two bits so that's that how do
you multiply essentially proceeds the
same way except that it gets a little
bit more the algebra gets a little bit
more complicated so when you multiply to
site X I again get a multiple of P plus
a small even nice it's not it's it's
it's much bigger than before because if
you start with the sort of an n-bit
noise
but so I started with an N high end to
the half bit noise and then to the half
bit noise and what I get is a 2 times n
to the half bet noise that's the
resulting right and if i take this mod p
and read off the least significant bit
again get the product of these two bets
macho ok so the homo markovic operation
am amar Kaleka discipline multiplication
is simply at adding and multiplying the
underlying integer ciphertext Josh why
don't you get in big noise oh yeah this
is our 1 tensor r1 times r2 is in bits x
22 in bizrate's the nervousness in the
room are one is quite o defend bits so
square roots we're Square rooted Oh
screamer sorry yeah reminder thank you
so it's too big that mistake what sort
of n n is it if you want to see serious
security that's a good question so it
depends on how secure we believe this
approx City problem is I don't have a
good enough answer to you and actually I
don't have any answer to so you have to
study this problem and see how difficult
it is and some of which we do in the
paper but we don't have a concrete
recommendation for what the security
parameters
so a good good good so um so this
problem has been known in various
different sort of forms and shapes
before so if you look at it a little
more carefully you can see that this is
a variant of the simultaneous de Fonteyn
approximation problem which is saying
that if I give you many fractions I give
you many fractions and you have to find
me a fractional number which
approximates each of these to each of
these sort of many numbers that I give
you this is a problem that was fairly
well studied but ligurious Jeff lagares
has a work on it from as far as 1982 and
people have studied this problem for a
for a while so the name was introduced
by how grave Graham like five years ago
you can only do a few applications oh
good so I'm
okay good so so you see that the least
bit is the product of the man great okay
good so clearly this scheme has two
problems one is that if i multiply two
ciphertext the size of the resulting
ciphertext cross right and essentially
it grows essentially when you compute a
big program on the ciphertext the
resulting ciphertext is as big as the
progress size of the program itself so
if you think in terms of the cloud
computing example the receiver gets this
huge ciphertext just reading the whole
thing takes it as much time as computing
the program so this is a huge problem
the I'm not going to talk in detail
about how we solve this problem but the
rough idea is that we give the server
another near multiple of P and every
time you do a homomorphic operation you
take take this mod this near multiple so
I'm not giving you any extra information
because it's another instead of giving
you 100 near multiple near multiple
Sophie give you 101 near multiples so
hardness of the problem doesn't change
very much but it decreases the size of
the ciphertext the more serious problem
is that the underlying noise in the
ciphertext gross whenever you add or
multiply numbers this is a this is a
slightly more serious problem to handle
and in fact the the the first thing that
we observe is that we can do a limited
number of additions and multiplications
already with this basics game and then
there is a way to bootstrap this limited
additions and multiplications to get
computation of an arbitrary circle this
is a very beautiful technique that Craig
Gentry introduced in his in its original
construction so putting these two things
together essentially solves our problem
good so this is QED all I wanted to say
right any questions
so how important is that
so you can make it a polynomial nap
let's say end to the 0.9 line and you
will still get so a the larger you make
that noise the larger your nice gross
when you do homework operations the
smaller the number for motor
corporations that you can do with this
basic scheme so you have to so amount of
noise dictates the amount of morphic
operations that you can do on the other
hand if you have a larger amount of
noise it's conceivable that the
underlying problem is harder right so
there's a trade-off here the smaller you
make the noise the easier the underlying
problem becomes and the more the
homework operations you can do so square
root of n is sort of an arbitrary number
which lets me do login multiplications
that's the sort of threshold I want to
wait well because the quadra plugin for
a plug
okay good so that's that in the rest of
the talk two slides i'm going to i want
to tell you a little bit about my
research philosophy and tell you about a
couple of open questions that that this
work leaves behind so I think
cryptography is an exciting field to
work because it both takes practical
problems problems that arise in practice
and solves it using very exciting
mathematical techniques so this
combination is is what makes for me what
makes cryptography a very exciting thing
to do what I told you about today is is
two applications too exciting
applications that if we solve using
photographic techniques first is
security again side-channel attacks so
in both these fields are very sort of
new fields they're just in their infancy
there's a lot of work to be done a big
question that it arises in the context
of security against our channel attacks
it is the following I showed you a
particular construction of public
interruption scheme that is secure
against a chance the question is can you
the big question is can you take any
program which is not necessarily secure
against side channels and immunize it
again sorry is there a general way of
transforming any program to a leakage
Sicilian program and that's like and I
want to do this while not killing the
what for this to be practical I want to
do this while not killing the efficiency
of the program this is I think very big
question in in this field number two
again the big question in the in the
context of computing unencrypted data is
how efficient can you make the fully
homomorphic encryption scheme the scheme
that I presented to you is a little bit
slow so it's a it's a it's polynomial
time but it's a big polynomial so
asymptotically I think we did a
back-of-the-envelope computation minute
even kept so optimize the exponent of
the the exact polynomial so I think the
number that we came up with was n to the
eighth so in other words if executing a
program takes K steps executing this
under the encryption takes n to the
eight times K steps where n is the
security parameter
the size of the universe sure so the
really big question here is can you do
this keenya it take this algorithm and
make some improvements in the
implementation that might already bring
down a that might already bring down the
complexity quite a quite quite a quite a
quite a lot and then the question can
you design the completely different
schemes which are dramatically more
efficient that's the big question one
thing that I didn't get to tell you
about is is my work on the mathematical
foundations of cryptography so a lot of
these works use either explicitly the
encryption schemes that I developed
based on lattices lattices of geometric
objects that it look like periodic grits
in space but it it they embed very hard
problems very hard computational
problems and this is a very new sort of
mathematical field that that we've based
cryptography on and it turns out that
the the schemes that we develop in this
context are useful in both protecting
against side channels and also the
insights were useful and constructing a
morphic interruption scheme so this is
another's of big set of problems that
that I'm interested in and that's that
questioned your integer lattice scheme
has a will of the flavor of the intro
schemes of work you use back its
relation or they just help so a so there
is no formal relation that I can prove
yet one superficial difference is that
the intro scheme in fact all lattice
based games use n dimensional analysis
and here we are just working with
integers I took that's a very
superficial difference but the real
answer to your question is that the lot
of the insights are the same in
constructing both these schemes but I
don't know for formal connection
I'll ask at this point this probably
something if he needs talk about offline
I just I'd love to get a better sense
for how they this moving works to keep
the error terms now I imagine that one
the slider to
yes in fact handling these two problems
that i mentioned is quite i mean it's
it's 15 full minutes affair of doc so
I'd be happy to those details why there
comes on so it comes out of the details
so if you look at the security parameter
that the rework with is the size of the
noise right so let's call that k which
is square root of n so the the prime
that I need to pick is of size case
quite right and it turns out to this
problem is actually easy if the multiple
that I choose the multiple q that I
choose is too small all right so I need
to pick that to be to the squire of this
size of pace that's gay to the fourth
and then the when I do this
bootstrapping process that already adds
a square of this number so that's k to
the eighth and not sure if this explains
anything but the complexity grows very
fast when you put all these steps
together
sounds more like the size steps
so that's probably not the number of
steps grows too and that's probably not
apparent from from what I described but
once you do this bootstrapping process
it the time required to process every
gate is essentially k to the power 8 the
size of these numbers so i can i can
explain this stuff lines comments on our
first half of your child so does it
actually instead of the shortest vector
grounds that actually reduce to the
closest metro problem it's not that so
it's not the closest vector problem and
it's a it's something that looks like
the close to a problem closest vector
problem says that you know i give you a
point and you're supposed to find the
really closest lattice point problem
that i'm looking at here says that i
give you a point in space you're
supposed to find some clothes yes some
clothes point within a certain radius
there are exponentially many clothes
points and supposed to find one
other questions